[Musique]
salut
est-ce qu'on peut essayer d'avoir un
comportement aussi normale que possible
oui ok pas de ce sentier ont fait ça tu
veux pas fait john hutton a vraiment du
mal à en parler de tuer mamie non pas du
tout c'est illégal pas vrai
comment vous allez faire ça va se passer
quand bientôt mon grand ça va oui
d'habitude je ne prends pas ce genre de
la crise vous dormez je vais bientôt
mourir vous joignez à nous ça devrait
faire les fragiles que tu laisses et
maman profité de ce week end sans que
tout tourne autour de ta personne à quoi
tu peux arrêter d'être gars c'est ce que
j'appellerais le 911 pour signaler une
tentative
et tu es sûr parce que elle elle a dit
qu'elle était prête elle est prête mais
moi pas
[Musique]
seul moment de le faire pendant qu'elle
était encore consciente de ce qui va se
passer
tu n'as pas peur depuis qu'on a choisi
une date j'ai arrêté de penser à la mort
et j'ai concentré toute mon énergie sur
la vie
cet héritage va être entièrement
dépensée en coq et ampute
[Musique]
mais t'as quoi dans la tête alors qui
doit la laisser faire ce qu'elle veut je
veux mieux la connaître
je veux qu'elle me traîner ce mois
[Musique]
mes petites filles
donner un conseil pour la vie le truc
c'est juste de se pointer et de faire du
souffle à cette merveille qu'est la vie
[Musique]